[Music]
i ended up doing a little deeper of a
dive and found an even cooler
extension to it but let me just tell you
the first thing you've done that was on
the article dive deep
i don't mean i did go to school for
journalism let's not forget [ __ ] you
did so you're living your dream right
no that was you're a hack peter parker
that was my major at uci but i dropped
out so it doesn't really count who cares
journalism is piece of [ __ ] today
just because you had a talented food for
lunch
wait you almost finished that italian
sub yeah i got a quarter left but yeah
you have one quarter left of school and
didn't finish bro so many people like
that hero or my
do you think you would ever finish just
so you could get your [ __ ] yeah
yeah like a steven spielberg
i don't think so i kind of
i kind of like the feeling of having an
unfinished symphony nice
thanks all right so this is this is what
happened here in denver a box of human
heads was stolen from a medical research
truck oh my god what they have a box of
human heads
there's a lot of questions that's what
was happening with that sticker on your
license
oh [ __ ] it's gonna be fine it's not even
an organ donor we gotta ask people all
the right questions for this so i mean
is it i just i'm just like
i just said igloo like a [ __ ] cooler
the home depot box decapitated head like
it's not even a nice box
plastic bag i see them on daggers and
spikes in the trunk
like fancy
a shrink head in a glass jar not the
stash yeah
yeah or like harry potter yeah
that's the taco
juice yeah
and how did the heist happen
the truck was parked and then somebody
just broke into it and jacked the head
why would you want this do you think
they just do you think they just took
the box and like this is gonna be some
good [ __ ] they opened it up and then
they had a panic attack
that was drugs it's the movie seven
brothers
[ __ ] heads
or they're like they they've been
scouting like the hospital
and they kind of know that these things
are cost a lot on the black market
what's the head go for on the black
market dude 10 g's bro i actually don't
actually know the price probably it goes
it goes for 2500 to like 3 500 bucks you
just google that so depending on how
pretty bro
you're gonna you want to listen
to jail right ryan's been tapping in the
dark web the whole time and now we're
gonna get flagged i'm an expert on head
but not the kind you're hey so here's
the thing legally heads go for about 500
600 bucks if it's medical research black
market prices are like four to five
times that so did they break in thinking
you know some other organs and they got
shared that's ps [ __ ] force still no
it's not even dude ps4 has cost more
than that
was it did they bring it to the event
ps4 thinking it was other stuff but they
just that day it was just heads okay
here's the thing that's interesting when
you just read like the surface article
about it that is the case they're trying
to play it like oh these robbers just
didn't know what they were stealing it's
kind of like people that rob the [ __ ]
pacific union train oh and they just
take all the amazon [ __ ] don't know
what's in it it's a [ __ ] unboxing
every day for them yeah that's the fun
part they just got tick-tock tights
look good though let me tell you there
are so many articles where it literally
just ends in that they go they probably
just didn't know what they were jacking
now they got some heads on them probably
i don't know what to do but your
journalism spidey sense was tingling and
you had to you had a deep dive yeah
you're almost almost graduated
journalism degree three credits thunder
knew something was up so my uciness
kicked in
and journalism kicked in i found this
entire like thing by this attorney named
michael berg
and this attorney
he's he's done these landmark cases
against people who secretly own an
interest in funeral homes and medical
research whoa and he exposed the
syndicate of people that are taking dead
bodies that did not sign to be donated
and selling them off to medical research
that's like that's like squid game bro
he discovered that there's no states
that has any law against uh you can just
open well you could just open your own
center of body donations without any
kind of permit what the [ __ ] type of
[ __ ] are we talking about i'm getting so
lost
what the [ __ ] are we in the matrix what
are we doing guys who own funeral homes
like i get it but i don't get it
i guess maybe i need like the finished
product of why
that's where i'm headed like where are
you guys
no but who's buying it like is it
chinese people
yeah there's these people called body
brokers
whoa that's cool
the one state
the one state that he had a landmark
case it was arizona and it was a 58
million dollar judgment against a body
broker who was illegally taking body
parts from funeral homes and selling
them to science and uh what scientists
are buying that they don't have to pass
no regulations
come on tony yeah
put flies on the people's
why do you need these heads hey can a
guy just like heads
it's for the body exhibit in las vegas
oh that's cool
those are tires all those people yeah
where are those [ __ ] coming
falun gong legal follow gong
retired dancers go to the body exhibit
that's a conspiracy where they buy it
from falun gong political dissidents in
china they get turned into
cadavers or whatever and then they
donate them to the body i've always
thought those bodies look very chinese
in my opinion they're all they're all 5
30.
wow
they're not samoan i'll tell you that
oh my god that's weird it doesn't look
like you see some six foot guys
you can't say that to anybody
yeah yeah it's the lower chance
someone's gonna look like you
just because i'm so unique
thank you guys you guys are so kind
those guys that look like you don't even
die
so uh so this is what uh berg has to say
about this
his whole view on this is that it's some
like set up thing but he obviously is a
lawyer so he's smart about not just
making random accusations but this is
what he said he goes these are the
questions that need to be asked whose
heads were these what was the purpose of
the heads where were they being
delivered to did the company have
consent
and he said they just skipped over all
that and all the other articles are just
saying oh they were stolen
that's it and who owned it
dude all of that where's the bodies oh i
got oh i got i gotta set a spine just
just in case for medical reasons
a couple hundred bucks let's swap it in
bearspine.com
i really wonder what people are doing
with like human heads on the black
market well in what science lab or
whatever because like a lot of science
is still done in universities you would
hope maybe there's some [ __ ] old guy
that thinks it's like a tiger blood and
he's like if i inject
elon musk and nearly dude he needs an
abundance of like a buck on a head
neurolink
he's selling them out
people could do blow jobs okay dude you
just went way [ __ ] dark all right
it's so heavy
come on man i don't know he's trying to
skull [ __ ] a jeffrey epstein would never
do that yeah he wouldn't do that
jeffy still tired of the regular [ __ ]
that's not his thing he's just never
given and now he wants dead people you
know what's funny is
when i hear what's next am i right
where are we going to go
adults
regular consensual sex
two and five grand of value each
number i'm thinking what is a
determining factor is it like oh this
one's hot this one died like this
they're pretty facing you know like this
one's an ugly face maybe how intact and
[ __ ] you press ahead they do have a they
do there's a meat there's like a metric
for it actually like by the insurance
policy by weight really yeah i don't i
was listening
right with me like if that if a guy had
triple a when he died it's kind of like
like like business around companies with
high hazardous high hazardous like work
there's like insurance policies out for
that's how people know like what costs
what oh because uh like yeah it's a
weird insurance thing but yeah they
still don't know why people are buying
these heads yeah decorations it's
science right yeah well that's that was
the intended destination
that's the intended destination but if
someone's gonna steal them from a truck
i mean are they stealing them for just
science over here black market wise if
it's not a live organ where you could
transplant it i'm thinking people are
eating it people are
displaying it
because it's cool to have like body
parts for some people you know like yeah
rock and roll just watch futurama and
he's trying to pull like a whole wall of
heads futurama how's that like
you said another landmark case from
arizona was like a 58 million dollar
like yeah like that's a [ __ ] yeah that's
a lot of hits let's do the math right
now if he was able to get that much in a
lawsuit against a body broker in arizona
58 million the value of what that person
was doing this only happens in nevada
and arizona dude yeah
those are the two states that shit's
going arizona
arizona that's right maybe the age of
you why did you move out there
bart hasn't said [ __ ] this whole video
he's like yeah it's jeffrey epstein
doing it all yeah
wow that's the price is only four
thousand it got ripped off he's like
that's so cheap i ripped off for it it
depends on how much i usually get a
photo
i had like a real human head just to
like display for 2500. you do it you
belong in jail 20 people
that's what i wanted is that even legal
can you do that can you just have a head
for fun i don't want to head science
i don't want to head in my house
i think you legally could have a head
but the ways you get that head are
probably illegal okay i'm gonna say
okay okay explaining it like uh
having and getting all right so so i'll
say ethically sourced head how about i
like that grass fed no no no because
some free range free range head yeah
because like some people they're against
taxidermy right
co-bay head
sounds like a hippie
dude it's really good let me tell you
grass finish the granola dome
but what are you gonna do you legally
got it you legally have it you totally
have it legally and it's sitting in your
house and somebody's like what the [ __ ]
like what's creepier if that's eddie if
you have a head it's my grandma
oh true yeah
bodies and keep them in the urn that's
normal and we burned the rest of them
but they can't look at you though you
know what i mean maybe maybe just keep
the eyeballs
[Laughter]
bro we've been talking about selling
epstein head all day and eyeballs don't
freak out
you're talking about edge about face
[ __ ] dead
[Music]
this lawyer guy he he asks a really cool
question he goes how is it possible that
you can't drive a car without a license
you can't even do nails without a
license but you can open a body donation
business with no qualifications no
license supervision regulations anywhere
across the country are we gonna get in
the body that's pretty crazy except
arizona thanks to him now they put they
have one law in place now because of his
case only arizona and he's trying to do
state-to-state like figure out what the
[ __ ] conspiracy sounds interesting dying
forever this business must be really old
right the oldest business
they do
if there's a birth business why is there
no death business
speak on it brother speak on it brother
speaker ten percent disorder i got mine
as legally sourced so
[Music]